hey youtubers is charlie new flash
footage confirms that jason rusch is
going to be on the show now we don't
know if he's going to be earth to jason
rusch and he'll be like the earth to
firestorm but I actually think what's
going on is something a little bit
closer to the transition between ronnie
raymond and jason rusch in the comics so
I'm just going to do a quick explainer
for the different versions of firestorm
in the comics and then what the show
might be doing to change that a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
starts now all you had to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video robbie amell the first person
to play firestorm on the show is Ronnie
Raymond that's the first version of
firestorm in the comics then during the
identity crisis storyline very
controversial for many reasons the
shadow thief steals the shining knight's
sword magical sword stabs Ronnie Raymond
with it as he's firestorm and it kills
him the TV show kind of explained how
unstable the firestorm matrix is they
created that special device to help them
control it in the comics when firestorm
gets stabbed with a magical blade it
ruptures his matrix and he completely
dissipates the residual energy fuses
with jason rusch who is nearby and he
becomes the new firestorm later in the
comics they rebooted the firestorm title
and they changed the backstory just a
little bit they changed how jason rusch
became firestorm and the newer version
of the story the firestorm matrix sought
jason rusch out on purpose it wasn't as
much of an accident it's like when
Oliver Queen tells Barry I think the
lightning chose you I don't think it was
an accident things got a little bit
crazier because if you remember Martin
Stein is typically part of the firestorm
matrix but at this point in the comics
they had like spun the character off and
he became this fire elemental that was
an outer space that had no idea what was
going on with Ronnie Raymond dying jason
rusch being the new firestorm he just
sensed that the firestorm matrix had
chosen a new host because jason rusch
was still trying to figure out his
powers and was derping a lot he asked
Martin Stein to become part of the
matrix again and eventually he relented
on the TV show you definitely need two
people to form the firestorm matrix but
in the comics there have been various
points when that wasn't necessary we're
like a single person could be firestorm
by themselves the cool thing is is that
eventually jason rusch ended up fusing
with a bunch of different people when
Martin Stein went away he actually got
access to other superheroes powers
whenever he fused with other superheroes
the confuses with fire hawk and gets
access to
her powers to not expecting the TV show
to do anything that crazy just expecting
Ronnie Raymond to make room for Jason
rush to take his place in the firestorm
matrix it's just like WWE in Ronnie
Raymond tags Jason rush in only two
people allowed in the ring at the same
time for about eight years though Ronnie
Raymond had been dead in the comics like
they just they basically wrote the
character off and jason rusch had been
firestorm during blackest night Geoff
Johns brought him back as a black
lantern and he became Deathstorm but
during that arc death storm actually
absorbs the jason rusch firestorm into
his matrix into his black lantern matrix
and just as all these evil things the
whole firestorm arc of blackest night
though was all about bringing Ronnie
Raymond back to life so he came back
into the comics and then in the new
firestorm comic after that after
blackest night there were two versions
of firestorm there was the Ronnie
Raymond firestorm in jason rusch
firestorm both at the same time that was
basically like the new 52 now obviously
the new 52 has been retconned again DC's
changed a bunch of things post
convergence so we have to find out what
they're going to be doing with firestorm
going forward but that's not going to
have anything to do with the TV show the
TV show is going to be truer to the
original versions of the stories so I
think Ronnie Raymond going away jason
rusch stepping in we just we don't know
how that's going to happen on the TV
show because we have this earth to stuff
going on we have multiverse so I know a
lot of you are wondering if jason rusch
is going to be the earth to firestorm I
don't think that's going to be the case
but it does kind of lay some groundwork
for this storyline of the new 52 called
the god particle where by Martin Stein
creates something called the god
particle that basically supercharges
firestorm and they end up fighting each
other and then fusing into like a
combiner like a transformer combiner
super firestorm called fury it's kind of
like when the spectre takes over Jim
Corrigan like he ceases to be Jim
Corrigan and takes on this otherworldly
persona the fury has its own persona too
and it's not completely good it's kind
of a gray area not a good character not
a bad character but here's what's
happening with the show so like arrow
the flash season 2 and legends of
tomorrow all kind of like one big show
done across three different shows it's
like it's the same universe same story
that's going to cross over all three
shows is a huge time commitment from an
actor's standpoint Robbie amell's film
careers taking off so he probably just
doesn't have the time to do 23 episodes
a year or something like that so
that's probably why they're taking the
opportunity to do jason rusch which is
actually a really interesting story
anyway it all just kind of works out so
that they can make some really good TV
with some really good drama so the first
eight or nine episodes are going to be
dedicated to introducing this new jason
rusch character and then explaining how
he eat Martin Stein go to legends of
tomorrow become part of that team but a
lot of you are also asking what about
the jason rusch since they cast from
season one we actually saw a version to
jason rusch that showed up during
firestorm storyline they probably just
recast the actor franz treme is the
actor that like they didn't say who he
was there like here's all these
characters are gonna be part you know
here's hawkman hawkgirl but they just
they didn't say who this character was
so frosted remain gonna be a recast
version of Jason rush this garage here
is actually where he works in the
context of the story he's kind of like a
college washout that used to be a
football player that got injured he's
working as a mechanic right now I don't
know if they're completely wiping the
backstory of jason rusch from season one
because he was part of the firestorm
program with Martin Stein they might
leave that in but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
idea of jason rusch becoming the new
firestorm and then killing off Ronnie
Raymond or do you think that it's going
to be earth to jason rusch I mean it's
possible but I don't think that's going
to be the case it also kind of laid some
groundwork for Caitlin snow to become
killer frost at a certain point which
which I don't think is gonna happen the
first half of the season and also on on
top of all that this is actually a shot
of zoom coming out of the wormhole that
Barry opened in the season finale so he
is going to be like the blue looking
flash it is because I've been talking
about the two different versions of
firestorm I really like the idea of
duality in the villain as in this
version of zoom is an evil version of
one of the good characters that we
already know on the show or that we will
meet during the course of the season if
you ever watch Buffy or angel back in
the day it's kind of like the Angelus
form of angel in other related good news
there actually was a little bit of new
arrow season for material I'll do a
video for that tomorrow just because I
was going to do a fear The Walking Dead
video right now before agents of shield
but then this firestorm stuff dropped
and I was like holy I got to do
this first so that's coming just stay
tuned on Twitter and Facebook for
updates on when videos are posting but
my agents of shield episode 1 video will
post tonight after the episode airs
that's what's coming next while you guys
wait for all that stuff to post you can
click here for all my other flash season
he owes aunt you can click here to get
ready for agents of shield tonight thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight